it's great to welcome back to the
program today congressman ro khanna
representing california's 17th district
which includes silicon valley joining us
today from a car
uh very much great great to have you
back on
david a park
um so okay supply chain shortages gas
prices
uh tchotchkes from china that are
expected to be christmas gifts you know
there's this there's this broad range of
what does milk cost what do toys cost
etc
initially there was the idea that this
is
a uh a demand resurgence after there was
a demand uh evaporation during the
pandemic it's now pretty clear that it's
more than that but what's your kind of
general assessment of what we're seeing
right now
well we're seeing inflation and this is
why
we need two things we need to pass
billbag better which would put more
money in the pockets of working families
so that they could pay for their
groceries and gas it would lower
prescription drug
prices it would deal with some of the
supply chain issues by investing money
in our ports by providing an incentive
for people to uh
return to uh return to work uh and so
we we need to pass it and then the fed
you know as larry summers has said the
fed uh needs to
to make sure that they stop in my view
the mortgage buybacks and stop
increasing the money supply
that's largely on the fed
and they can take that action
let's pick one item which is gas prices
because it gets so much attention you
know for years i have not participated
in the
you either blame or praise the president
for what's going on with gas prices
my best assessment is if a president
wants they can tap into the strategic
reserve which
will eventually lower gas prices maybe
18 to 20 cents a gallon on what might be
a temporary basis i mean it seems really
that presidents don't have very much to
do with gas prices but yet it's a very
popular political football to throw
around isn't it
well this president i think did the
right thing by uh having tapping the
strategic patrol reserve 18 cents uh
per gallon is uh significant i mean
that's uh
means a lot to folks who are who are
struggling uh but in terms of
dramatically lowering prices it uh has
more to do with the the oil companies i
mean they didn't when when oil was 22 30
bucks a barrel they didn't invest now
that it's uh much higher they're
they they want to reap the benefits and
so the long-term solution to this is
price stability which is more electric
vehicles more renewable energy so that
we're not dictating
we're not at the mercy of the vagaries
of the price of oil uh but uh in the
short term i think president obama is
taking the right action uh when you when
we look at some of some other things
like for example uh used cars have been
a big area of price increase starting
with the pandemic and continuing through
building materials is another one
although it seems that lumber is sort of
coming back down
how involved
do you believe a government should be on
individual areas like these in trying to
influence price
as involved as we can be i mean we have
to be realistic that the governments
usually
don't have that many tools to to fight
inflation i mean it goes back to gerald
ford with wind and whip inflation and
you know it's very hard to do but we
should do
what we can in this case i think the
three things we need to do is put more
money in the pockets of working families
so that they have money to deal with the
higher prices make sure we're dealing
with supply chain issues at the ports
and make sure we're incentivizing more
people to work so that
you can deal with some of these supply
issues and and lower prices i guess i'd
have one more thing which is if there's
concentrated industry making sure people
aren't charging uh prices above the
competitive price and uh putting
pressure on those industries to charge a
fair price there's a i guess we would
call it plausible maybe we don't have to
say probable yet that republicans may
well take control of the house of
representatives back next year and and
would assume control in january of
given that we don't know at least what
will happen after next november
what do you believe realistically can
get done in terms of major legislation
in the next year uh that that would pass
not only the house but actually the
senate and become law
well first of all we need to make sure
we win or it's a devastating for uh our
democracy i mean to have people like
marjorie taylor greene and others
in charge after the house of
representatives is a fake that uh really
no one in my view and the democratic
side should should want and shouldn't
take uh should take very seriously i i
think we have to obviously we have to
pass buildback better which will lower
prescription drug costs lower child care
costs lower elder care costs
we need to in my view deliver on the 15
minimum wage the president can
unilaterally forgive student loans he
ought to do
that have some forgiveness of student
loans voting rights we have to deliver
voting rights this is our
chance to do it or we're basically stuck
with state
voter suppression laws uh and we need to
make sure that we're
tackling immigration i mean if it
doesn't make it into build bag better
there has to be some delivering
on immigration so those would be some of
the things i think that are the
priorities for next year on on student
loans i get a lot of emails from people
who say i'm really mad that joe biden is
not moving more quickly on forgiving
some student loan debt i came into this
presidency not believing that joe biden
had any intention of doing that i'm not
i'm not praising or or saying i'm mad at
him i just never thought that this was a
priority for joe biden i didn't think he
was going to forgive any student debt
is that your view or do you think that
that's something he might be able to be
pressured to do
i think he should be persuaded to do it
i think it could help really build
support uh in
with him with with young people around
the country and it's the right thing to
do uh and he understands that we're
being married to
the first lady who's a an educator how
much debt we're saddling the younger
generation with now i don't think he's
going to do 50 000 as senator warren
senator schumer and i and others have
asked but could he do 10 20 000 and
would that materially make a difference
in people's lives absolutely and i i
think it would be one of the biggest
things he could do to build momentum for
his presidency
you mentioned marjorie taylor green as
some in my audience know the house voted
to stripper of her committee assignments
uh some months ago
uh your colleague ayanna pressley has
now
suggested uh proposed doing the same
with with lauren beaubert over her
multiple recent videos related to
stories about being in elevators with
ilhan omar and the jihad squad etc uh
are when what's your view about doing
that because it's obviously correct on
the merits and i would go further that
these folks have no business even being
in the house of representatives but is
it not a pyrrhic victory in some sense
where they end up saying i've been
cancelled to donate money and it gives
them
attention well david you're actually
right i was talking to a friend of mine
on the republican side yesterday and he
said when are you going to kick me off
my committee so i can go raise a million
bucks i got an email to my uh
my list so this is why i think the
speaker is being judicious about this
discussing it obviously we have to take
action it has to be clear that that kind
of racism that kind of islamophobia has
no place but we don't want to make
representative bobera martyr uh and and
do something that's going to further
fuel uh her platform and that's
why i think the speaker's taking her
time consulting the caucus i will
support uh whatever action she ends up
taking we do need to take some action
behind sometimes we learn that
there are interesting political
bedfellows behind the scenes where
publicly there's a lot of conflict and
they're friends behind the scenes
right now with some of these
personalities that exist for example
this rift between congresswoman bo bird
and and ilhan omar
is there more palpable tension behind
the scenes where it is not nearly as
collegial as it tends to be
i think on some of the fringes yes there
are a few people who probably
you don't
interact with you don't even sometimes
say hi to
but not among the vast majority i mean i
still have
good relations on the other side i was
speaking i speak often to representative
calmer we disagree strongly on issues of
oil and gas other issues but he's
always engages in good faith there are
you know dozens of members on the other
side who i still work with you have to
get legislation through
i want to talk a little bit about um the
general approach that you think the
democratic party should take going into
the 2022 election one of the things that
makes it increasingly tough to run
against the kind of modern republicans
of the trump and post-trump era is for
the most part they're not even
pretending to be about policy anymore
they're about obstruction they're about
cultural issues like critical race
theory or a christmas tree was burned
and it's part of the war on christmas or
whatever the case may be so that's very
silly but it also makes it sort of tough
to run against them because if they're
not arguing on policy it's hard to fight
against things like the left wants to
turn this country into a socialist
country or these kind of vague
statements so how how do you run against
that i'm not convinced that just
continuing to talk about policy like a
train
is actually is is what's effective
well we lead with patriotism we talked
about how uh we have an aspirational
vision for america we have a vision in
america where uh we actually win the
21st century we're proud of being
americans everyone should be taught to
be uh proud of being americans and what
we want to make sure is people shouldn't
have to be forced to leave their
hometowns we need to bring prosperity
uh and and modern opportunity to places
that have long uh been left out so that
they could have dignity so they can stay
kids can stay with their families and
that you know trump promised all these
things but he hasn't delivered and we
will to to build a strong vibrant great
america uh i think we don't emphasize
the patriotism enough the aspiration
enough you have to get to people's
hearts to get them to think yeah they
really have a vision that they care
about this country they care about my
community
and then you can get into the specifics
but you can't lead with the specifics
without
what is the end what is that what is the
purpose human beings aren't just
economic actors yeah that's what seems
extraordinarily difficult about the
situation which is
i feel very strongly that when there is
a policy debate we win the policy debate
very clearly but if the if the
circumstances don't allow you to be
speaking to a public that is expecting
to have the policy debate and instead
they want the debate over who is
socialist or patriotic or whatever the
case may be it feels like a losing
battle in some sense
well we can win that debate that our
values are the true
american values our values of the
freedom of ideas and expression of
respect for people of all faiths of a
respect for a
if uh civility a decency uh these are
the american values that we're standing
up for in the fulfillment of those
values and of spreading opportunity and
prosperity i think we ought to frame
them as uh we're standing up for the
deepest uh american values the
fundamental american values and not that
we're here's our five-point plan
just to put more money in your pocket
that matters but people care uh
holistically they want to see our nation
thrive and succeed and they want to know
what their place is in this nation and
we have to speak to that deeper
aspiration that people have and and
people are very much vote on identity
before i let you go um i'm curious now
in thinking about 2022 of course every
member of the house is up for
re-election many in very safe seats so
the number of truly contested seats is
of course only a fraction of the total
one-third of the senate is is of course
up there's a number of governors races
etc how much talk behind the scenes is
there about the role that the former
president donald trump is going to try
to play either in general in the
midterms or in in specific races and
does it really matter in terms of the
strategy for democrats
i do think he's going to play a role
he's already playing a role in georgia
challenging an incumbent governor he's
challenging some sitting house members
i i think it it provides an opportunity
for democrats to when the republican
party is so divided and they're uh still
having people who are denying joe
biden's legitimate election uh running
for office on that platform but i don't
think it's sufficient for democrats i
think
it gives us an opportunity
to compete to not be written off
to maintain our majority but we have to
have a vision that delivers for people
and that convinces them that we really
are speaking to what what matters to
them and matters them not just
economically matters to their conception
of our country and only if we do that
can we can we keep the house do you
think the virginia gubernatorial from
last month was a warning about making it
too much about running against trumpism
because young can seem to kind of
ride the fence well enough that it was
not a good strategy
yeah i don't think it should be all
about trump i think it could be also
about some of the extremes in congress
who basically said look do you want some
of these people to be cheering the next
committees and to be
in charge of the the new congress but
then i think it has to be a clear vision
on our side of what we've delivered what
we're going to continue to deliver uh
what we stand for people
ultimately need the positive the
affirmative to vote for someone yeah the
the more i look at next year the more
i'm of the mindset of uh hope for the
best and and prepare for the worst and
hopefully it works out not not too
poorly congressman ro khanna
representing california's 17th district
always appreciate your time
thank you david i always enjoy being on